[Música]
olha que detalhe sobre veronica matos
fernandez tenho 37 anos e sou daqui por
escolha
eu gostaria de saber quem nasceu em
jaraguá do sul a vocês quem nasceu em
jaraguá do sul
quer dizer o meu muito obrigada eu sou
muito grata essa cidade há 15 anos eu
notei jaraguá do sul e o meu muito
obrigado a todos que elas recebe para
quem se abre para ela eu gostaria sim um
aplauso para jaraguá do sul
[Aplausos]
essa cidade que é naturalmente de
imigrantes assim como conta a história
com emílio carlos jourdan seu fundador
um belga que trouxe com ele 60
trabalhadores entre negros e brancos e
assim com um boom industrial alemães
italianos poloneses entre outros
hoje em dia com os hatianos e essa
mistura que traz pessoas de toda a
região do brasil
assim como tem uma grande empresa em
jaraguá do sul que em 61 63 por cento
dos seus trabalhadores que não nasceram
jaraguá
isso mostra de fato a realidade que é
jaraguá do sul
essa mistura de raças e credos que é o
resultado do brasil uma miscigenação sim
de culturas
eu eu nasci em rivera no norte do
uruguai um país pequeno com 13 milhões e
meio de habitantes e no ano de 2000
aproximadamente ele passou por uma
grande crise
nessa crise eu falo que faz a gente se
reconectar e estar mais presente lidar
com a crise em casa com a falta do
desemprego falta de saúde com a família
naquele momento sim eu me perguntei eu
teria sim de fazer novas escolhas e
aquele momento avaliando a situação eu
ficava aguardava a crise passar ou
criava novas oportunidades e poderia ver
que eu vi foi no brasil porque o brasil
o brasil sim por ser um país de
fronteira no brasil por trazer toda essa
cultura que sempre me encantou desde
criança na sua culinária então realmente
são sabor
na sua música sempre divulgando
encantamento e desde então eu decidi vir
próximos 20 anos de idade e naquele
momento eu decidi por santa catarina
porque santa catarina santa catarina
desde a sua beleza natural que é do mar
à serra
isso trouxe pra mim o que eu sou o que
eu sou terra e lá eu vim e com a cara ea
coragem eu lembro que eu cheguei em
florianópolis ea cidade também se sente
acolhida foi canasvieiras uma cidade que
até o momento não sentia acolhida porque
eu falo que o idioma oficial é o lula
que está como está
então naquele momento me senti acolhida
mas não consegui emprego
a família passou necessidade e eu em
busca realmente desse novo horizonte e
aí comecei a me informar e que eu teria
uma das possibilidades melhores para
balneário camboriú e itapema eu cheguei
em itapema em itapema
eu lembro que estava prestes a completar
21 anos de idade
e aí eu consegui uma quitinete que tinha
tudo montado e mobiliado a cozinha
naquele momento me vi sozinha sem
emprego sem família e realmente passou
um filme na minha cabeça fazer
aniversário pra mim é fechar um ciclo e
começar um novo ciclo
naquele momento eu decidi comemorar o
aniversário
eu fiz um bolo pra mim naquele momento
eu sozinho lembra que passava uma
vizinha
naquele momento aguentou nenhum outro o
aroma está gostoso e fechou a porta
naquele momento eu falei olha eu aqui
sozinha eu vou ficou pronto e eu aqui na
porta da cozinha e veio bolo e falei
olha que talhe só a verônica nova
vizinha ela com um olhar muito
expressivo de espanto surpresa e ao
mesmo tempo um olhar acolhedor
foi ela me deu os parabéns
ela preparou um gostoso café naquele
momento novamente veio a sensação do
acolhimento e pra mim fazer e receber
alguém traz esse acolhimento
aí as coisas foram assaí o tempo foi
passando e eu lembro que na semana
conseguir emprego e eu muito feliz mas
eu não questionei o salário
eu queria um emprego quando vi a
realidade do salário
eu vi que mal daria pra suprir as minha
né
as minhas necessidades e não teria que
estar ajudando a minha família
naquele momento eu liguei pra minha mãe
que até hoje ou na verdade hoje eu
ganhei uma consciência ou aquela
resposta e ela me respondeu mecânica aí
a ser porque ela respondeu pra mim
verônica aí você está sozinha faça por
você
aqui nós temos um ao outro
hoje essa resposta ela me remete àquele
manual que recebemos quando a gente
entrou no avião em caso de emergência
se essas máscaras caírem
primeiro coloque a sua
depois auxilia quem instalado ali eu
aprendi que de fato se não estamos bem
não podemos ajudar
é egoísmo e dali
o tempo foi passando e foi realmente me
ajustando e foi construída a verônica
partir daquele momento e os 23 anos de
idade foi me apresentado jaraguá do sul
como uma cidade de oportunidades
fiquei encantada
na primeira vez pelo verde é uma
sensação que o que eu tinha da cidade no
acolhimento pequena mas como nem tudo
são flores mulher solteira com essa
independência teve sim a questão do
preconceito uma redução de serão agora
até programa
naquele momento me trouxe pra mim uma
avaliação do pessoal postura é que de
onde eu venho o abraço toque o beijo é o
carinho por receber sem o estigma sexual
mas aí você enfrenta uma nova cultura e
não conhece você e você também acabaram
conhecendo e aí vem o tempo ea permissão
eu me permite conhecer me permite deixar
ser conhecida
o tempo foi passando e realmente tudo
foi se ajustando e foram conhecendo de
fato quem era verônica hoje
eu vejo que realmente valeu a pena
sim hoje eu tenho uma clínica de
estética e bem está só esteticista
massoterapeuta de formação e o meu dia a
dia
lidar com pessoas é agradecer
ora ora a cada pessoa que entra
transmitir esse bem-estar traz famin
esse acolhimento que eu recebi lá atrás
eu carrego comigo é a gratidão e de fato
as coisas às vezes quando são difíceis a
gente se questiona ela fala não se
preocupe se tá difícil vai piorar e
nesse momento não desistir e não
desistir e lembro que aquele dia
quinhentos reais no bolso
eu teria que estar escolhendo se sim eu
comprava um macarrão instantâneo ou eu
pegava minha condução de ônibus naquele
momento naquele dia eu lembro sim de ter
chorado e somente me perguntei se a
escolha quem assiste sido a escolha
correta mas aí de fato eu vi que tudo
tem um porquê
desejo que o tempo foi passando aí as
horas foram passando e eu jurei que a
partir daquele momento jamais me
perguntaria o porquê está acontecendo
isso ou aquilo e senhor para que é para
o aprendizado
é sim para uma evolução e principalmente
para uma aceitação e só os desafios que
estave a mente nossos olhos
o que eu posso dizer é que de fato
passou e de fato as coisas foram
acontecendo mas sem desistir
todo dia é um novo dia
agora o que me fez ficar em jaraguá do
sul
eu lembro aquele dia que eu desci na
rodoviária da cidade
ela tinha um perfume tutti frutti
eu lembro como se fosse hoje
era o cheiro que era o perfume e eu
identifico perfume desafiou o som sim
dos pássaros e do trem e chama muita
atenção mas o que de fato me fez ficar
em jaraguá
essas amizades pessoas de verdade é a
alma e um par de olhos azuis que foi um
encontro de almas
esse foi um acolhimento e o que eu posso
dizer é que realmente as coisas estão em
nossas mãos
basta a gente olhar sim com carinho com
muita verdade aqui dentro
tô que a gaz aceita conversar e ponto
coração no independiente que o último
tudo que você fizer faça assim o seu
coração e com verdade independente das
conseqüências
basta unicamente uma pessoa certa para
que você chegue onde jamais chegaria
sozinho é obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]